the Joe Rogan experience don't you see
the the Hong Kong protests that are
going on
no this crazy protest going on in Hong
Kong but what's amazing is there was an
ambulance and the ambulance was trying
to I mean these giant crowds on the
street I mean [ __ ] thousands if not
millions a part like the sea for this
for this ambulance it's crazy like if
that [ __ ] was happening in America good
block you could blow that horn all you
want
what is this Jamie we're gonna sit you
know mmm why does it say North Point not
like Chinese characters on the street
yeah you sure this is the one Hong Kong
protesters bak whoa make way for
ambulance I saw an overhead shot of it
it was more impressive because it was
this giant sea of people and they all
just made way and everybody got right
the [ __ ] out of the way for ambulances
it's like when a predatory fish swims
like a small school so here it is this
is what I saw yeah so these people just
open up good luck trying that [ __ ] in
America I mean these people are so
polite
millions of protesters like two to three
million ourselves yeah what do you know
what they're protesting I can't there's
so much outrage worldwide I can't keep
track man yeah there's stuff going on
everywhere you see that there's this
stuff in Sudan right now everywhere you
know every part of the world is up in
arms
Gaza there's a bunch of [ __ ] going on
ever enough ever you know there's a new
more recent [ __ ] it's exhausting yeah
like why can't people just not be
[ __ ] right that's impossible
that's what we need this mind-reading
software a problem with that is like
then you just reading the mind of
[ __ ] maybe maybe but maybe people
can let you know okay man do you don't
have to think like that your problem is
the way you're thinking
cuz it's 90% the problem with people is
the way they think and then they act on
the way they think I don't know if it
90% of them really not a mouth petition
just threw that number out there
[Applause]